Könnten Sie bitte mir ein Vorname langsamer werden?
Ja, der Vorname ist RALF.
Und der Familienname ist Kühler.
U-Umblaut.
Kühler.
Herr Kühler.
Ich bin 58.
Wann sind Sie genannt geboren?
Am 8.06.1967.
Wie viel wiegen Sie da Zeit?
Ja, ich wiege so 87 Kilo.
Wie groß sind Sie?
78.
Vielen Dank Herr Kühler.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was tut Sie heute so uns?
Ja, wissen Sie, mir ist vorhin das ganz Blöde passiert.
Ich hatte mit einmal, ich bin irgendwie spät dran gewesen
und bin in meinem Büro schnell die Treppe hoch gelaufen.
Und mit einmal hatte ich solche starken Schmerzen,
hinter der Brust, so in der Brust.
Das ist ganz plötzlich gekommen.
Das strahlte so aus.
Mit einmal tat mir der Unterkiefer wie Puh.
Das hat gebrannt und war ganz unheimlich.
Und ich hatte auch tatsächlich ein bisschen Panik.
Mir war plötzlich unheimlich schlecht.
Ich war schweißnass, ich habe total geschwitzt.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, ich kriege auch nicht gut Luft.
Dann haben die Kollegen mich auf der Treppe gefunden
und sind mit mir nach oben ins Büro.
Dann ging es mir ein bisschen besser, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Aber die haben gesagt, du musst sofort zum Arten.
Dann bin ich gleich hierher gekommen.
Die haben mich mit dem Auto mitgenommen.
Seit wann haben sie diese Bischwärme?
Ja, das ist jetzt vielleicht so zwei Stunden her.
Zwei Stunden.
Jetzt ist es zum Glück wieder besser.
Das hat sich wirklich sehr schrecklich angefühlt.
Das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Das ist eine gute Entscheidung für ihre Gesundheit.
Dass sie bei uns ins Krankenhaus gekommen sind.
Ich wüsste gar nicht, wie ich alleine damit hätte klarkommen können.
Das war richtig beängstigend.
Seit zwei Stunden.
Ihr könnt mir beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen sind.
Sind sie drückend, stehend, siehend oder brennend?
Das ist einmal drückt, das ist ganz toll.
Das ist so, so dieser Druck,
dass es so wie ein Elefant hier auf der Brust sitzt.
Und auch dieses Brennen,
was bis hier unten den Unterkiefer so raus gestrahlt hat.
Ich habe die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, herkühler.
Noch mal ein bisschen die Frage.
Sagen Sie doch einmal die Frage, bitte.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Kurze Vorzehnen sind die schon, also bei acht bestimmt.
Das sind so richtig krasse Schmerzen.
Zum Glück ist es jetzt ein bisschen besser.
Ich habe jetzt keinen Elefanten mehr auf der Brust sitzen.
Das fühlt sich wirklich so an.
Okay, herkühler, das ist ein Notfall.
Momentan würde ich, muss ich ihre Vitalparamete überwachen.
Was heißt das?
Wie Blutdruck, Blutdruck messen,
ihre Sauerstoffsetigung kontrollieren.
Und ihr Puls kontrollieren.
Und dann muss ich EKG schreiben.
Das habe ich mir schon gedacht, dass sie in EKG machen müssen.
Okay, und danach muss ich mobilisieren.
Monetisieren.
Monitorieren.
Also dann komme ich an so ein Apparat dran.
Genau, mit dem.
Und dann reden wir weiter.
Genau, okay.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, ich hätte gar nicht gewusst, was dagegen hilft.
Also könnte ich Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen, ich habe nichts eingenommen.
Okay, haben Sie bekannte Allergie gegen Medikamente?
Ja, ich weiß, dass ich keinen Lovagin vertrage.
Momentan gebe ich Ihnen ein Schmeißenmutter.
Nein, das ist vielleicht gut.
Ja, dass ich auch ein bisschen auf sein Lovagin.
Okay.
Gut, also das haben wir unter so einem gemacht.
Ich hänge am Monitor, ich lebe.
Genau.
Wir konnten Sie weiterfragen.
Genau, nach der Untersuchung fühlen Sie sich besser?
Ja, also dass das jetzt überwacht wird, ist schon eine Beruhigung für mich.
Ich hatte wirklich, ich hatte richtig Angst eben, ja.
Ja, ich weiß, dass ich verstehe.
Können wir das Aufnahmegeschüpfe fortgehen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, weiterfragen.
Okay.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass die Schmeißen plötzlich aufgezeichnet sind.
Ja, als ich die Treppe da hoch gerannt bin, ja.
Beim Treppensteigen.
Wie viel Minuten dauert es?
Oh, das kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen.
Es kam mir wie in der Ewigkeit vor, aber wahrscheinlich war das gar nicht so lange.
Also wenn Sie durch die Schmerzen haben, geht die Zeit gar nicht, ja.
Eine Stunde oder 30 Minuten?
Ja, vielleicht eine halbe Stunde.
Ich kann das für ich nicht gut einschätzen, ja.
Okay, ja.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen ein Auslöser für diese Beschwerden, für diese Schäden?
Da habe ich ja gesagt, ich bin die Treppe hoch gerade, ich war in einer Eile, ein Stress.
Nur Treppensteigen und genau.
Ja, und Hektik ist für Stress nicht, weil es spät dran, ne?
Okay, Stress.
Haben Sie sonstige Beschwerden, Herr Kühler?
Haben Sie Schwitzen?
Ja, Sie haben schon einmal...
Ich habe gedacht, ich war mit einem Art Schnapp geschwitzt.
Ja, bei Martes Schwitzen.
Okay, haben Sie das bewusst verloren?
Ne, ich habe alles mitgekriegt die ganze Zeit.
Okay.
Haben Sie Husten oder Herzrasen, Herzstolpen?
Ja, also das Herz, das hat schon ein bisschen komisch gemacht, ja.
Das hat sich komisch angefühlt.
Also ich hatte das Gefühl, dass das ganz schnell schlägt, ja.
Okay.
Abgesehen von Ihren Beschwerden, haben Sie Fibar Stülphrosodah nach Schweiß?
Ne, also nachts schwitze ich normalerweise nicht, nachts muss ich nur mal zwischenflüge auf die Toilette, aber sonst...
Ja, und manchmal habe ich nachts so ein bisschen das Problem, dass ich, wenn ich dann aufwache, dass ich denke,
ich kriege nicht so gut Luft oder muss ich mich so ein bisschen auf die Bettkante setzen.
Ja, ich möchte zusammenfassen.
Beim Aufwachen, haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, also ich wach manchmal auf, weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich kriege keine Luft so, ne?
Okay.
Wie schlafen Sie, Herr Kühler?
Na, wie alle Leute schlafen im Bett natürlich.
Ja, haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Ich sagte doch, ich schlafe nachts einmal oder zweimal zur Toilette, ne?
Ich habe ein bisschen Frost-A-Tab-Probleme in meinem Alter ja nicht so ungewöhnlicher.
Okay.
Frost-A-Tab.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit Sturrgang?
Ne, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, also das funktioniert eigentlich alles ganz gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ab- oder Zugenomen?
Also ich sieg mich jetzt nicht jeden Tag, aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, dass ich besonders Ab- oder Zugenommen habe.
Die Hosen passen alle noch, die Händen passen noch, also ja, ich glaube nicht, dass ich Gewicht verändert habe.
Okay.
Wahrscheinlich konstant.
Ja!
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen bestimmt die Telekronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie ein Frost-A-Tab-Problem haben.
Ja, und das ist das eine und das, was man halt so hat in dem Alter ja.
Ich habe seit, ja, seit fünf Jahren diesen Alterszucker, ja, und dann nehme ich halt eine Tablette
und dann sind die Blutfettwerte ein bisschen hoch und der Blutbrück ist auch ein bisschen zu hoch,
aber dann ist alles nicht so wild eigentlich.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben Blutfettwerte, ja, das Kolesterol ist immer ein bisschen zu hoch.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Becher verdient?
Ja, das hat man festgestellt so vor fünf Jahren ungefähr.
Okay, und seit wann haben Sie Frost-A-Tab-Probleme?
Ja, das ist noch nicht so lange, aber also ich war da beim Urologen
und der hat gesagt, das ist im Augenblick alles unauffällig.
Okay.
Vor fünf Jahren oder?
Nein, das hat jetzt erst vor zwei Jahren oder so angefangen.
Vor zwei Jahren, okay.
Haben Sie Frost-A-Tab-Probleme oder?
Ja, er sagt, die ist ein bisschen vergrößert, aber so nichts, nichts Schlimmes.
Okay.
Okay, wurden Sie schon mal operiert, Herr Kühler?
Ja, also, nee, direkt operiert wurde ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich war zwar im Krankenhaus, aber da bin ich ja nur zur Beobachtung.
Wir sind nie in der Operation, war das gar nicht.
Nee, ich bin gar nicht noch nie operiert worden.
Okay, wieso haben Sie im Krankenhaus?
Ja, ich war da im Krankenhaus, da hatte ich vor acht Jahren ein Verkehrsunfall
und da bin ich eine Nacht zur Kontrolle da geblieben,
weil ich mit dem Kopf aufgestoßen bin so ein bisschen
und den Airbag halt abbekommen habe.
Und da hat man zur Vorsicht, hat man mich eine Nacht im Krankenhaus
zur Überwachung da gelassen.
Okay, können Sie nochmal oder wiederholen, Krupp auf?
Ja, ich hatte einen Autounfall und der Airbag hat ausgelöst.
Und dann bin ich halt so in den Airbag reingeknallt
und man war nicht sicher, ob mit dem Kopf irgendwas ist.
Okay, wahrscheinlich Kopfverletzung.
Okay, vor acht Jahren.
Vor acht Jahren.
Okay, nehmen Sie die Regalmisi mit die Kommentare ein.
Ja klar, also einmal dieses Zuckermedikament, das Metformin,
das nehme ich einmal morgens.
Und dann habe ich einen Betablucker, den nehme ich auch morgens
und dann habe ich noch enalapril, das nehme ich auch morgens eine Tablette.
Okay, in welche Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Das kann ich, den Metformin ist meine 800, kann das sein?
Die Dosierung 800, ich meine, da steht 800 drauf.
Okay.
Und bei den anderen kann ich ihn jetzt nicht so tun.
In welche Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Noch mal bitte.
Nein.
Die Verbindung ist schlecht, ich kann sie schlecht hören.
Noch mal bitte.
In welche Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Ich weiß nicht, was da drauf steht.
Ich weiß nur, ich nehme morgens eine Tablette und eine Tablette
von dem enalapril.
Müste ich jetzt zu Hause nachgucken, was da drauf steht.
Ja, okay, okay, ja, kein Problem.
Sind Sie vorstandig geimpft, Herr Kula?
So viel ich weiß, ja, also Sie meinen gegen Covid oder so,
ja, da bin ich geimpft.
Viermal, viermal, ja.
Covid oder gegen Influenza, gegen Lungenentzündung.
Lungenentzündung, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht.
Aber also die Grippeimpfung, das mache ich eigentlich auch jedes Jahr.
Warns Ihnen das, seit im Ausland, Oyser Novalgin,
ja, also wo ich langengemäme reagiere mit so einem Ausschlag,
das ist Latex, also wenn jemand so Gummihandschuhe hat
oder so, das kann ich nicht vertragen.
Okay, okay, wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Kriege ich einen Ausschlag?
Ausschlag.
Okay, ich habe eine Ausflag.
Ich habe eine Ausflag.
Ausflag.
Okay.
Und für Novalgin, wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, da habe ich auch einen Ausschlag bekommen
und das ist sogar auch so weit gegangen,
dass ich so das Gefühl hatte, ich kriege keine Luft mehr.
Okay.
Rausen Sie, Herr Pula?
Ja, aber nur noch ganz wenig, ich habe das sehr reduziert.
Ich habe auch nur noch so 5 bis 10 Zigaretten am Tag.
Okay, seit wann rauchen Sie?
Schon lange, schon fast 30 Jahre.
Also früher habe ich so ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht,
aber wie gesagt, das habe ich deutlich reduziert.
Okay.
Ja, wie viele Jahre haben Sie eine Schachtel geraucht?
Ja, so 28 Jahre bestimmt, ja.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Pula?
Ja, ich trinke gerne mal Glas Wein, ja.
Jeden Tag oder?
Nein, nicht jeden Tag, das bietet sich ja nicht an,
aber also ein paar Mal in der Woche so, ja.
Okay, in der Woche.
Ja, speziell, wenn es natürlich was zu feiern gibt
und es dann am Wochenende oder so, ne?
Ja, ne.
Nächste Frage ist Routine Frage, Herr Pula,
wie haben Sie die Jemenstrugen konsumiert?
Drugen?
Nein, da habe ich mich nie dran getraut, das habe ich nie gemacht.
Okay.
Sind in Ihrer Familie bestimmt die Krankungen bekannt?
Ja, so meine Mutter hat genauso wie ich auch diesen Alterszucker da,
aber ist damit eigentlich jetzt schon ziemlich alt geworden.
Und mein Vater, ja, der hatte eine Herzerkrankung
und ich weiß, dass der auch immer sehr hohen Blutdruck hatte und so.
Und aber der ist eigentlich auch alt geworden,
der ist mit 83 leastig gestorben, ja.
Aber da hatte der wohl irgendwie eine größere Herzattacke.
Okay.
Haben Sie die Schwester?
Nein, ich war ein Zulkind.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Pula?
Was ich wo mache?
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Innenarchitekt und selbstständig.
Ich habe also eine eigene...
Architekt?
Okay.
Arbeiten Sie selbst?
Ich arbeite selbst, ja, natürlich.
Klar, sonst kommt nichts rein, ja.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet, lebe allerdings von meiner Frau getrennt.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin noch verheiratet.
Wir sind jetzt im Trennungsjahr, ja, aber...
also wir leben eben nicht mehr zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder, aber die leben bei meiner Frau.
Okay.
Und der älteste ist auch schon so gut wie aus dem Haus, ja.
Ja, warten Sie unter Schittress in der Arbeit, Herr Pula?
Oder in privaten Nebens?
Ja, natürlich.
Also so eine Situation mit Vorständigerschaltung,
das macht man nicht mehr so eben einfach.
Und als Selbständiger hat man natürlich auch immer Druck.
Und ja, und wie gesagt, jetzt heute Morgen
musste alles ganz schnell gehen,
und da war ich auch unter ordentlich Stress, ja.
Okay.
Okay, nehmen Sie Medikament oder etwas gegen Schittress ein, oder?
Dann trinke ich eher abends lieber ein Glas Wein zum Einschlafen, ja.
Dann nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Okay, ja.
Das kann ich sehr gut verstehen.
Okay, Herr Pula.
Damit sind wir mit der Frage durch.
Möchtest du noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich will natürlich jetzt wissen, ob so was nochmal wieder passiert
und was man dagegen tun kann.
Und wie sehen jetzt meinen EKG, sieht es gut aus?
Ist da irgendwas Gefährliches oder?
Das wüsste ich natürlich gerne.
Ja, das kann ich sehr gut verstehen.
Momentan kann ich in den noch nicht sehr zahm, was zahlb.
Genauso ist es, hier nicht normal EKG, Schreiben.
Ich bin in Brutalbkenowm, in Spezondere,
Herz, Enzyme, Rekorstieren.
Und ich habe auch noch ein bisschen
eine operative Massnahme machen.
Was für operative Massnahmen?
Eko-Kardiografie.
Also so eine Ultraschall-Untersuchung oder was?
Genau, Ultraschall für Herz.
Für Herz, okay.
Und was kann man da sehen?
Ja, wir können, boy,
dass Herz gut funktioniert.
Ob das gut funktioniert?
Ja, ob es da nette ist.
Kann man das nicht im EKG sehen?
Ja, EKG ist Schmerzlos und dauerhaft...
EKG kenne ich ja, das habe ich ja schon ein paar Mal in meinem Leben gemacht.
Aber landet es nicht, kann man da nicht genug sehen,
ob das Herz gut funktioniert?
Ja, EKG zeigte sich diese Ergebnisse,
aber Ultraschall ist die beste für Herz,
gut funktioniert.
Da kann man es gut beurteilen, ja?
Genau, genau.
Ja, gut, aber wenn das nicht wehtut, ist es ja auch okay.
Möchten Sie noch etwas zuvogeln, oder haben Sie noch eine Frage?
Ja, vielleicht auch so, was kann man in Zukunft machen,
wenn man wieder so einen Anfall hat?
Das ist ja furchtbar, wenn man solche Angst hat und solche Schmerzen.
Genau, das kann ich sehr gut verstehen, Herr Kühler.
Aber wenn ich Ihre Ergebnisse habe,
beschreiben wir die weiteren Schritte.
Ja, das klingt vernünftig, ja.
Gut, danke schön.
Vielen Dank und nehmen Sie bitte einen Platz.
Ja, aber in der Monitor läuft ja noch, ne?
Ja, genau.
Ich rufe so schnell auf.
Okay, gut.
Also genau genommen liege ich ja als Patient irgendwo jetzt
auf der Untersuchungsliege und bin...
Genau, war bestimmt...
Hab den Finger irgendwo in der Sauerstoff- und Liegungsmesser...
Genau, Saustoff-System...
...und haben die Elektroden vom EKG irgendwo auf der Brust kleben, ne?
Ja, also kann ich mich nicht gut ins Wartezimmer setzen,
sondern sie müssen schon sein, ich komme gleich wieder, ne?
Ja, gut, okay.
Dann möchte ich jemand von den Kollegen und Kolleginnen
noch was anderes fragen, zusätzliche Fragen.
Da hat hier etwas zu tun.
Hallo.
Ja, hallo.
Hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden in der Vergangenheit?
Ja, auf die Frage habe ich die ganze Zeit gewartet, ja.
Gut, ja, tatsächlich, also beim Treffenlaufen
da hatte ich schon mal so ein bisschen Probleme, ja.
Dass ich ein bisschen das Gefühl hatte, so...
So, ich krieg jetzt nicht gut Luft oder so, ich muss jetzt mal stehen bleiben.
Aber so heftige Schmerzen wie jetzt, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Beine geschwollen sind in der letzten Zeit?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Okay, werden wir untersuchen, okay.
Ich habe diese Frage vergessen.
Haben Sie Übelkeit und Erwrichen?
Ja, schlecht war mir im Sinne von...
Ja, also schlecht war mir und Angst hatte ich, aber übergeben musste ich mich nicht.
Okay, ja, ich probiere.
Okay, gut.
Guten Tag, gut, dass ich Sie treffe.
Ja, heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten.
Haben Sie kurz seit Vorzustellen?
Ja, natürlich, wir haben die den gesehen.
Okay.
Es sind diese Umrafe Kühler, er ist 58 Jahre alt und 178 cm.
Er wird auf eine Art Kühle.
Er ist auf einer Art Kühle, der sich ein bisschen aufgemacht hat.
Er hat eine Art Kühle, die sich ein bisschen aufgemacht hat.
Torax Schimarsson.
Die Schimarsson werden als Berenna
Die Verbindung ist schlecht.
Können Sie das mal wieder holen?
Hallo, können Sie bitte das mal holen?
Frau Gildes, die Verbindung ist ganz schlecht.
Das letzte konnte ich überhaupt nicht verstehen.
Ich habe das nicht gesehen.
Können Sie das mal holen?
Ja, jetzt kann ich sie gut hören.
Okay.
Die Schimarsson werden als Berenna
und die Verbindung ist schlecht.
Das letzte konnte ich überhaupt nicht verstehen.
Das letzte konnte ich nicht verstehen.
Und jetzt hatte er keine Schmerzen mehr.
Augustisch habe ich nicht gehört.
Hatte er jetzt immer noch Schmerzen?
Genau, genau.
Okay.
Ja, was denn, du?
Haben die eine halbe Stunde angedauert
oder hat er jetzt immer noch Schmerzen?
Dauerhaft.
Okay.
Genau, dauerhaft.
Nach Angaben des Patienten
sieht die Schmerzen beim Treppensteigen aufgetreten.
Und die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft.
Der Patient wurde mit dem Auto gebracht.
Bei uns ins Krankenhaus mit dem Auto gebracht.
Von wem?
Mit Freunden?
Kuling, ne?
Ja, ne.
Und die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 8 von 10
auf der numerischen Ratingskala bewertet.
Und der Patient über Femmeertes Schwitzen
oder Schweißausbrühe?
Ständig, oder nur jetzt?
Oder Hyperhidrosis?
Ja, hat er das ständig?
Ist das eine bekannte Vorerkrankung
oder die Hyperhidrosis?
Ja, wahrscheinlich Schweißausbrühe.
Er hatte jetzt einen Schweißausbruch bei diesem Anfall.
Okay, gut.
Und das hat er noch geschildert?
Genau.
Und neusehr...
...düsne.
Wir haben wieder keinen Ton.
Ich trage nach...
...enne hab ich schon mal den früher.
Und...
...die hab ich schon mal den früher.
Frau Dr. Hilden, ich kriege nur ganz kleine Bruchstücke
von ihren Sördern.
Die Wege anamnäse.
Ich kriege praktisch nichts mit, was sie sagen.
Das ist ganz...
Das ist ne ganz brüchige Verbindung.
Ich krieg nur so kleine Wortfetzen.
Sagen Sie bitte noch einmal...
...ja, das kann sein, dass wir wetterbedingt
vielleicht Netzprobleme haben oder Stromprobleme.
Das könnte schon sein.
Können Sie...
So kann ich Sie beschönern, ja?
Ist schade, dass wir uns nicht sehen.
Aber es ist besser, als wenn ich kein einziges Wort verstehe.
Gut, jetzt müssen wir noch mal gucken, wo wir waren.
Also was beschreibt der Patient an Leben?
Der Patient berichtet über Dispne,
Taukardi,
Schweißausbrühe und Moisea.
Sehr gut, okay.
Und die Wege anamnäse.
Das ist unaufwählig.
Wir sind auf Nikturi.
Wir sind auf der Toilette.
Genau.
Also, grüßlich.
Okay, gut.
Okay.
Das ist der Unfall.
Welchen Unfall?
Wegen...
Genau. Vor acht Jahren war er zwei Mal im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Wie zwei Nächte oder wie?
Wegen... oder zweimal.
Er hatte einen Unfall?
Genau. Zwei Mal im Krankenhaus geblieben.
Wegen eines Unfalls ist er zweimal im Krankenhaus geblieben?
Genau. Wegen eines Unfalls.
Okay. Ja, fast...
Nein, ein Unfall.
Wegen eines Unfalls, einmal.
Verrückter Unfall.
Wegen der Kopfverletzung.
War er einmal im Krankenhaus...
Zur Beobachtung, das ist er geblieben.
Ja.
Ernähme Regen, Metformin, 800 Milligramm, einmal morgens.
Beta-Blockö, einmal morgens.
Und NL-April einmal morgens ein.
Der Name von Beta-Blockö sei unbekannt.
Der Impfstatus sei vollständig.
Der Reisenamnese sei unauffällig.
Sei oder ist?
Ist... Konjektiv 1.
Bitte?
Ja, Konjektiv 1.
Nee, Sie haben ihn gefragt, ob er an einem auffälligen Ort war.
Er hat keine Reise in die Karibik gemacht, war nicht in Afrika oder in Brasilien oder sonstwo.
Sondern er war nur in Nachbarländern.
Also ist die Reise an Annese unauffällig.
Der Patient weiß nicht, ob das auffällig ist oder nicht.
Er kann ihm zwar sagen, was er für Beschwerden hat, aber ob seine Reise an Annese unauffällig ist, das können Sie nur beurteilen.
Genau, vielen Dank.
Die Reise an Annese ist unauffällig.
Er habe bekannte Allergie gegen...
Bekannte Allergie gegen Novagin und Latex.
Er reagiert auf Novagin.
Ja, hoffen wir, dass es...
Okay, hören Sie...
Jetzt klingt gut, ja.
Ich weiß nicht.
Er habe bekannte Allergie gegen Novagin und Latex.
Er reagiert auf Novagin mit exentem und Dispne.
Und er reagiert auf Latex mit exentem.
Und es besteht ein Nikotin-Abusus.
Er ist seit 30 Jahren...
...sind 20 Jahre...
...sind 28 Jahre...
...sind 1 Schachtel Zigaretten geraucht.
Und seit 2 Jahren...
...sind 5 bis 10 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Also kommen da auf knapp 29 Packiers, ne?
Genau.
Er trinkt in der Englisch-Wein in der Woche...
...inspezionäre...
...inspezionäre Luschlafen.
Ah, ja, okay.
Okay, Drogenkonsum, wurde fein gehalten.
Zahne muta, habe diabetes Melitus, zahne fatta...
...habe...
...habe hate Herzerkrankung...
...und eine andere Hypertonie.
Im Atem von 83 Jahre sei er gestorben.
Er ist ein Kind.
Momentan arbeite er als Architekt.
Momentan?
Arbite er als Architekt.
Wieso arbeitet er momentan als Architekt?
Er arbeitet immer als Architekt.
Das ist sein Beruf, er ist ja selbstständig, ne?
Er ist Architekt.
Und verheiratet, aber...
...in diesem Jahr ist er getrennt.
Ja, man nennt das Trennungsjahne.
Wenn ein Ehepaar sich entschließt, sich scheiden zu lassen,
muss man ein Trennungsjahne hinterdenken.
Trennungsjahne.
Und zu haben drehen, ja, sie wohnen mit ihrem Mutha.
Und in der Arbeit leidet er unter Stress.
Und privat nicht.
Nicht privat in der Arbeit.
Okay, ja, so ne Scheidung ist ja schon ein bisschen Stress, oder?
Wahrscheinlich.
Ja, wahrscheinlich schon, ja.
Okay, gut, ja, wie geht's weiter?
Okay, die Ananaschenangabe in der Oetne Amesin auf...
...akute Coronazendromhin.
...Astheferenzialdiagnosen, common.
...Ulkusventücule.
Okay, und was macht?
Und...myocardinfact.
Ja.
Was spricht für ein Ulkusventrikuli?
Um...Ja, Ulkusventrikuli,
...Shiprate, ...Torax Schimmersen,
...Bezonders, ja, Bezonders, Schütteral...
...Schütteral, Schütteral, Schütteral, Aus.
Okay.
...Yocardinfact.
Und...
Was haben Sie denn diagnostisch bisher gemacht?
Ähm, okay.
So weiter dann Abklärung, würde ich bei den Patienten,
ja, die Vitalparameter überwachen, die Körperli-Untersuchung durchführen
und...
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Körperli-Untersuchung.
Und...
Was haben Sie denn diagnostisch bisher gemacht?
Ähm, die Vitalparameter...
Ich höre Herzab.
Und bei der Herz-Rhythmus-Probleme,
höre ich Ab.
Und bei der...
...Palpation, ja.
Gena, Noah Abhörung, was ich an den Haber gemacht habe.
Ja, aber Sie haben doch noch Augen im Kopf.
Sie gucken doch noch nach bestimmten Sachen.
Augen.
Ja, ich kontrolliere...
...Vitalparameter, insbesondere Sauerstoffsetigung.
So, sorry, ich war rausgeflogen.
Mich hat es rausgeworfen. Ich musste nochmal Neustarten.
Entschuldigung, bitte.
So, ist unsere Ärztin noch da? Nee, die ist auch weg.
Das ist ja verrückt.
Ja.
Wahrscheinlich klingt sie sich aber auch gleich wieder ein. Hoffen wir mal.
Also bei mir war mit einmal... war mit einmal Schluss.
War das noch bei jemandem?
Hätte noch jemand das gleiche Problem, das ja rausgeflogen ist?
Nein.
Nein, bei uns nicht.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob wir unsere Frau Doktor noch wieder kriegen.
Aber solche technischen Probleme hatten wir schon ewig nicht mehr, ne?
Das ist sehr ungewöhnlich.
Da kommt sie wieder.
Ja, sorry.
Ich wurde mir leid, Frau Wiechmann. Heute...
Na, ich war auch weg.
Mich hat es auch rausgeworfen, komplett.
Ich war... ich musste auch neu starten.
Es ist nicht gut. Es wird mir leid.
Ja, könnte beide nichts dafür.
Ist halt so. Ja.
Gut, erzählen Sie mal weiter, was Sie mit den Patienten machen
und worauf Sie gucken.
Ja, meine Damen, doch zum Beispiel...
Ja, eh...
...Zu Janose, genau.
Dann hat ein Kollege gefragt, nach geschwollenen Beinen.
Genau. Ich achte auf...
...Ödem in den Beinen.
Janose, Hautbläse.
Hautbläse, genau.
Schweiß aus, oder Kälte...
Kälte-Schweiß.
Halten-Schweiß, ja.
Und, ja, eine Laborung, der so hoch ist,
ist sinnvoll, um die...
...Unfassende Diagnose zu gewerleisten.
Welche Werte bestimmen Sie?
Besonders, insbesondere würde ich...
...Herz Enzyme, wie Kreativinkinas Untroponim...
Troponim, hm hm hm.
...und Nebar-Untinir-Werte,
ja, Entsündungswerte wie CRP...
...Bestimin-Nasen, Elektro-Lüten,
Bestimin-Nasen.
Und, ja, unbedingt würde ich AKG schreiben.
Ja, das haben Sie doch schon gemacht.
Ja, ja, alles schon gemacht.
Ja, also, das haben Sie gar nicht berichtet.
Genau, AKG zeigte sich...
...Erhöfte-ST-Elevation...
...und...
Das ist jetzt ein Punkt, also,
wir kommen schon praktisch gleich in die weitere Besprechung.
Ja, ja.
Sie haben das gar nicht berichtet.
Sie haben das ja richtig gemacht.
Sie haben unterbrochen...
...Hm hm.
Sie haben unterbrochen und haben den Computer,
den Patienten monitorisiert, ja.
Sie haben ihn also...
...EKG geschrieben und haben...
...was, was ich, messen Blutdruck und messen...
...die Stauertoff-Sättigung, ja.
Also, das müssen Sie aber auch berichten.
Ja, Sie müssen uns sagen, ja, ich hab den Patienten...
...als ich gemerkt habe, wo es geht,
habe ich den sofort, ne,
da habe ich die Vitalparameter kontrolliert...
...und ich habe schon die ersten EKG-Befunde vorliegen.
Und normalerweise denke ich,
würde man doch auch in einem solchen Fall...
...sofort Blut abnehmen
und Troponien ins Labor geben, weil das ja dauert.
Genau.
Also, ich denke mal schon,
dass man das eigentlich so machen würde.
Es ist halt jetzt eine vertragte Situation,
weil wir diese künstliche Zoom-Situation haben.
Ich bin kein echter Patient
und ich hänge nicht tatsächlich am Monitor.
Sie sehen keine Werte von mir, ja.
Sie können das nur spekulativ machen, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie machen Laborwerte,
Sie machen EKG und Vitalparameterüberwachung.
Sie gucken, Sie hören das Herz selber ab, ja.
Und dann haben Sie den Patienten ja noch gesagt,
Sie machen operative Untersuchungen
und was machen Sie da?
Operative Untersuchungen.
Ja, ich habe schon gesagt, EKG
und Echokardiografie.
Echokardiografie, genau.
Das als erstes untersucht.
Und dann guckt man weiter.
Sollte sich die Verdacht diagnozibistätikieren,
würde ich dann Patienten stationär aufnehmen
und ich würde Monaterapie empfehlen, Morphin.
Also das ist die Tätik.
Monaterapie empfehlen und ich würde ein kardiologisches Konsul
um die Therapie zu optimieren.
Gut.
So, ich glaube, wir können jetzt schon gleich
ein bisschen zur Manöverkritik kommen.
Also abgesehen von unseren technischen Problemen,
die wir ohne Zweifel heute hatten,
sehe ich ein kleines Problem
in dem Augenblick, wo Sie etwas erklären müssen.
In dem Moment, als der Patient sie gefragt hat,
was kann man denn im Ultraschall mehr sehen
als im EKG, da sind Sie wirklich in Schwimmen gekommen.
Da haben Sie gesagt, ja, da kann man was sehen
und da kann man was sehen,
aber Sie konnten es eigentlich nicht erklären.
Was denn der Vorteil der Ultraschall-Untersuchung
ist oder was der an Zusatzinformationen gibt.
Und natürlich haben wir diese künstliche Situation,
dass Sie die Untersuchung, die Befragung unterbrechen müssen,
um die Vitalparameter zu testen.
Das ist sicherlich ein entscheidender und richtiger Schritt gewesen
in unserem Gespräch,
dass Sie gesagt haben, oh, Sie schildern das so und so,
da müssen wir mal gucken.
Was mir nicht so gut gefallen hat,
dass Sie eigentlich, ja, der Patient hat ja gesagt,
es war nach 30 Minuten,
waren diese ganz schlimmen Symptome besser.
Also er hat keine dauerhaften Schmerzen.
Sondern er ist jetzt wieder ein bisschen,
hat sich ein bisschen beruhigt sozusagen.
Sonst hätten Sie ihn auch gar nicht befragen können.
Wenn er noch mit acht von zehn
und Todesangst und Luftnot,
wenn er immer noch so schlecht gewesen wäre,
hätten Sie ihn ja gar nicht befragen können.
Dann wäre er hier mit Blaulicht gekommen.
Ich muss noch mal fragen,
wie stark sind die Schmerzen momentan auf einer Skala?
Er hat ja gesagt, die Schmerzen waren acht von zehn.
Er hatte also schon krasse Schmerzen.
Und was ich eigentlich auch nicht ausreichend finde zu sagen,
der hatte Thorax-Schmerzen.
Er hatte ja diese, er hat das ja eigentlich beschrieben,
er hat diesen Druckschmerz auf der Brust.
Und das sind ja, er hat gesagt,
ihn nutzt ein Elefant auf der Brust.
Retro-Sternale-Schmerzen.
Das, denke ich, hätte zwingend kommen müssen.
Dem hat er nicht der ganze Brustkopf weh getan,
sondern er hatte das direkt hinterm Brustbein.
Hier oben hat ihm jemand draufgehockt.
Dann hatten Sie nicht gefragt, ob er so etwas früher schon mal erlebt hat.
Die Frage kam dann von einem Kollegen.
Und eigentlich haben Sie auch in der Beschreibung dieses Entstehen.
Sie haben gesagt, beim Treppensteigen ist es gekommen.
Und das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Er hatte dieses Entstehen.
Sie haben gesagt, beim Treppensteigen ist es gekommen.
Nein, er war total in Hektik.
Er hatte, er war spät dran.
Und er hatte einen wichtigen Termin.
Und er ist gerannt.
Und er ist die Treppe hochgerannt.
Und, also er hatte Stress und körperliche Belastung.
Und das hat diese Attacke ausgelöst.
Und das hat er ihnen auch so geschildert.
Und er hat dann eigentlich auch, ja eigentlich so ein bisschen im Schwall hat er so erzählt.
Oh, ihm war so schlecht.
Und er hat geschwitzt und er hatte Angst.
Und dann haben sie ihn gefragt.
Haben sie, haben sie stark geschwitzt.
Ja, hat er gerade gesagt.
Also sie müssen schon hinhören, was der Patient ihnen erzählt.
Und müssen das alles notieren.
Und dann dürfen sie nicht nochmal danach fragen.
Sonst fühlt er sich ein bisschen veräppelt.
Genau, ja, akustisch habe ich vorhin nicht genutzt.
Ja, das lag tatsächlich an unserem technischen Grund.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Gut.
Dann haben wir diese Geschichte gehabt mit den Vorerkrankungen.
Ja, das sollte man schon dazu sagen, dass es ein Diabetes Typ 2 ist.
Auch bei der Mutter.
Ein zweier Diabetes, ja.
Da hat er ja gesagt, dieser typische Altersdiabetes,
da sollten wir schon dazu sagen, dass es ein Typ 2 ist.
Ja, Allergien waren richtig da, weil so ein bisschen unvermittelt kamen die Sachen.
Ich finde es schon immer ganz schön, wenn man sagt,
bei der Frage nach der Familienanamnese,
gab der Patient das und das an.
Sozialanamnestisch beschreibt er sich als selbständigen Innenarchitekten.
Er hat Stress zwar auch bei der Arbeit, aber auch durch private Dinge.
Er ist verheiratet, aber praktisch bevorstehende Scheidung, Kinder leben nicht bei ihm.
Das sind schon Faktoren, die natürlich Stress machen.
Aber das muss man auch ein bisschen verpacken.
Da muss man nicht sagen, also nicht Punkt für Punkt einfach nur aufzählen,
sondern sagen, was was ich.
Noxenanamnese ergab folgendes, der Patient raucht seit 2 Jahren reduziert,
aber davor hat er eben 28 Jahre lang eine Packung am Tag geraucht.
Das wäre so von der Präsentation eben ein bisschen schöner.
So, was haben wir noch?
Vegetative Anamnese finde ich immer nicht unauffällig,
wenn jemand nachts nicht schlafen kann, wenn der Luftnoten nachts
und wegen der Prostata nachts auf die Toilette geht,
ist die Anamnese nicht komplett unauffällig.
Vegetative Anamnese, nach meiner Meinung.
Gut, ja, Frau Gildes, können wir noch mal uns angucken?
Kriegen wir das noch mal hin, dass sie noch mal Kamera einmachen?
Ja, da ist sie wieder.
Also, die Fragen kommen...
Ja, wegen der Verbindung, wo sie mit dem Foto sind,
die sind bei der Verbindung noch schlechter.
Aber konnten Sie hören, was ich gesagt habe?
Ja, ja, ich habe...
Sie haben gehört, okay, gut.
Also, wenn Sie Standardschragen stellen,
haben Sie keine großen sprachlichen Probleme.
Manchmal verstehe ich Sie nicht gut,
weil Sie, was ich, glaube ich, auch schon mehrfach
anderen Kollegen gesagt habe, die Stimme sitzt ziemlich weit hinten im Hals
und dann artikulieren sie nicht so gut vorne.
Und dann muss man ein bisschen genau hinhören
oder ich muss auch manchmal nachfragen,
was aber auch tatsächlich jetzt wieder mit unserer technischen Verbindung zusammenhängen kann.
Machen Sie sich klar, dass Patienten oder auch Kollege nachfragen können,
dass da in der Prüfung auch Fragen kommen können,
auf die Sie nicht vorbereitet sind.
Auch dann müssen Sie aber richtige Antworten formulieren.
Ja, und das sind ja alles Fragen, die mit Ihrem Thema zusammenhängen.
Also mit den potentiellen Untersuchungen.
Es könnte sein, dass die Kollegen eben nachfragen,
was sie bisher schon an Voruntersuchungen gemacht haben.
Und da müssen Sie plausibler Antworten haben
und die müssen auch richtig formuliert sein.
Also lassen Sie sich nicht überraschen von Nachfragen,
sondern seien Sie auch da drauf vorbereitet.
Und dazu müssen Sie einfach,
vielleicht ein paar Standardformulierungen sich machen,
damit Sie da souverän antworten können.
Kann ich Ihnen nur als Empfehlung geben.
Okay, ja, ich denke mal,
dass als denkbare Differenzialdiagnose auf alle Fälle
noch die Lungenembolie hätte kommen können
und an Genapektoris.
Und der echte Myocardinfarkt,
den kann man sicherlich auch in dem Fall nicht ausschließen,
hat ja nicht eine ziemlich krasse Symptomatik geschildert.
Ansonsten Coronare-Herzerkrankungen, akute Geschichten.
Hämotox, oder ja, vielleicht auch noch.
Aber das wäre schon ein bisschen exotisch.
Und ich meine nicht zu vergessen,
der Vater ist hier offensichtlich an einer Herzerkrankung verstorben.
Da sollte man das Thema fraglichen infarkt,
sicherlich nicht ganz auf die leichte Schulter nehmen.
Gut, ja, das ist übrigens tatsächlich ein Münchnerfall hier, den wir haben.
Aber es gibt ja analoge Fälle in allen.
Coronare-Herzerkrankungen gibt es ja in allen Prüfungspools mit drin.
Gut, ja, ich hoffe, sie konnten trotz unserer Störung,
die wir jetzt hatten und Abbrüche,
ein bisschen was mitnehmen und ein bisschen was profitieren
von der Übung heute, es war ein bisschen anstrengend.
Auch durch meine Husterei, ehrlich gesagt.
Dankeschön für heute, wir sehen uns am Dienstag wieder.
Da können wir uns ein weiteres Mal treffen.
Dr. Pupil, Sie haben wahrscheinlich schon jemanden im Auge,
der dann macht, ich weiß es nicht.
Und bis dahin wünsche ich Ihnen erst mal alles Gute,
kommen Sie gut durch alle Witterungsumwillen,
die im Augenblick gerade auf uns warten.
Und ja, wir sehen uns am Dienstag, okay?
Ja, vielen Dank, wir freuen uns im Dienstag nochmal.
Alles klar.
Gut, also tschüss bis dahin, schönen Abend für heute.
Tschüss, schönen Abend.